déjà je pense que tout part de mon père
à la base parce que c'est lui qui très
tôt mme a
toujours été un bon shooteur donc en
regardant mais aussi en en mettant
certaines limites angers c'est pour moi
mon shoot c'est vraiment son projet à
lui c'est un peu je suis frankenstein on
veut dire quoi
très tôt j'ai eu droit à beaucoup de ces
deux vidéos regarde la coque où il est
comme ça il faut le mettre comme ça avec
des petits gadgets ou des choses comme
ça quand les copains à l'entraînement
shooter du milieu de terrain moi je
n'avais pas le droit ça pouvait ça
pouvait bouleversé la la mécanique s'il
était de mettre trop de forces dans le
geste ou plein de choses comme ça quand
tu commences à avoir 14 15 con tu veux
monter la balle au dessus de la tête et
que moi je n'ai pas assez de force j'ai
encore dû attendre une des années pour
pour que ça reste toujours assez fluide
donc rien à dire je pense que c'est ça
prend de lui à la base mais depuis
depuis j'ai appris à eybens à faire
beaucoup de répétitions beaucoup de
répétitions mais en développant en
développant différents comment dire
différents outils en plus par exemple
par exemple maintenant je fais je fais
par exemple de la visualisation avant
les matchs des choses comme ça je
regarde beaucoup de vidéos d'autres
shooter tu vois kyle korver de djirédji
qu'un jeune jaycee carroll en euroligue
des des choses comme ça
je vais essayer je vais essayer de me
documenter et puis après quoi comme dit
je suis aussi tombé sur des
décodeurs dernière surtout dernièrement
parce qu'avant j'ai toujours beaucoup
travaillé individuellement mais des fois
c'était peut-être un peu désordonné mais
depuis que j'ai rencontré jo gomis à
l'asvel eh ben
dans cette nouvelle profession qui est
un peu coach individuel donc giacomi
salah devait louis lassina voix dit au
csp eh ben eh ben tu te rends compte tu
peux passer un cap encore parce que
parce que tout est plus structuré tout
et tu vas direct à l'essentiel et
des personnes qui m'ont aidé à mieux
travailler encore on va dire donc
donc pour moi c'est c'est fin de la
répétition mais pas non plus faire
n'importe quoi essayer aussi de prendre
des shoots en situation de match est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux faire un show de
situations de match où 5000 shoot à deux
à l'heure où tu vois donc ccd fait un
questionnement au quotidien et c'est de
s'améliorer même s'il a pas forcément de
bonne réponse mais toujours essayer
maintenant dans le procès c'est comme
quand tu dis que tu regardes d'autres
shooter c'est qu'est-ce que tu regardes
précisément c'est la façon dont ça poser
des appuis si on va vraiment dans le
détail le le enfin comment est aligné
quelle partie du corps avec une autre le
comment sont tournés les épaules
qu'est-ce que tu regarde exactement chez
ses joueurs oui effectivement je regarde
je regarde ça schlingue capable de
compter par exemple après l'installeur
exactement combien de paris va faire
pour voir si par exemple si il en fait
si c'est moi j'en fais cette c'est pas
la fin du monde mais s'il en fait si
c'est que j'en fais 12 c'est qu'il ya un
souci par exemple
donc des choses comme ça tu vas tu
regardes un match des warriors j'adore
les warriors que les thompson steve
curie pas pour pas pour le show bat pour
les dream entre les jambes mais tu vas
des fois je regarde même pas la balle je
regarde juste comment comment comment
ketum sony va bouger tu as tu te dis que
tu commences à réfléchir un peu tu dis
comment ces gars là où tout le monde
sait que c'est eux qui vont shooter
comment ça se fait qu'à la fin ils
arrivent quand même à être ce que tu
vois c'est qu'il ya il faut dix font des
choses ils font des mouvements sans
ballon des choses comme ça pour à la fin
réussira à trouver un shoot est ce
qu'ils feront qu est ce qui fait que
maintenant il va faire une fan de shoot
pour laisser passer le gars est d'avoir
un shoot amherst à trois points derrière
ou est-ce qu'il va shooter rapidement
fin tu vois des n'ya pas qu'il n'ya pas
que ces gens là et même un jingle des
des joueurs comme ça c'est à tous et
tous ces gens je regarde beaucoup et
j'ai fait devrait vraiment être dans
l'est dans les détails